Malaria strikes when parasites are transmitted
into the body, through the bites of infected
mosquitoes.
With about 200 million cases worldwide, and
more than 400-thousand deaths each year, malaria
is a major burden on global health.
The current standard method for malaria diagnosis,
in the field, is light microscopy of blood
films which involves the manual counting of
parasites.
About 170 million blood films are examined
every year for malaria.
Accurate parasite counts are essential to
diagnosing malaria correctly, testing for
drug-resistance, measuring drug-effectiveness,
and classifying disease severity.
However, microscopic diagnostics is not standardized
and depends heavily upon the experience and skill
of the person peering through the microscope.
To improve malaria diagnostics, the National
Library of Medicine, and our collaborators,
are developing Malaria Screener a fully-automated
system for parasite detection and counting
in blood films.
Malaria Screener is a software application
that runs on a common smartphone utilizing
the phone's camera, to conduct automated malaria
screening in the field.
An adapter connects the phone to the eyepiece
of a microscope allowing Malaria Screener
to automatically analyze the blood film images
captured by the smartphone camera.
Automatic parasite counting has several advantages
compared to manual counting:
It provides a more reliable and standardized
interpretation of blood films.
It allows more patients to be served by reducing
the workload of the malaria field workers.
And, it reduces diagnostic costs.
To count parasites automatically, the system
uses image processing methods, to find parasites
in digitized images of blood films.
The system first learns the typical shape
and visual appearance of parasites based upon
manually-annotated training images.
Machine learning methods then detect the presence
of parasites perform the counting and discriminate
between parasite-infected and non-infected
cells.
The system can process digital images acquired
on standard, light microscopy equipment, which
makes it well-suited for resource-poor settings.
We are seeking partners to work with us to
demonstrate and evaluate Malaria Screener's
efficacy in the field.
We hope that it will develop into an effective
tool to fight malaria throughout the world.